I'm absolutely here for the Grimace
shakes will kill you Trend but so many
questions starting with is Grimace a
monster yes Grimace is most definitely a
monster when he was introduced in 1971
he had four arms looked kind of scaly
and stole milkshakes from children which
is terrifying and rude McDonald's
realized pretty quickly driving kids
away was not good for business and
Grimace was made over into the amorphous
purple blob we know and love today
Grimace Laura says he might be shaped to
look like a taste bud weird though the
official stand to sees the embodiment of
a milkshake which is just as weird could
this original evil Grimace Incarnation
be behind the deadly milkshake Trend the
best I can figure it is that Grimace is
a byproduct of the 1970s and some
corporate branding practices and this
month the internet made him their own by
injecting some horror back into Ronald's
best friend another win for modern pop
culture monsters and capitalism